after well over a month of record high
gas prices president joe biden has
finally settled on a strategy for
bringing prices down at the pump
no he is not going to issue new leases
for oil and gas production
and no
he isn't going to green light new oil
pipelines to encourage domestic
production and distribution and no
he isn't even going to increase releases
from the strategic petroleum reserve
instead
you see what president biden is going to
do
is ask
gas stations to lower prices
the companies running gas stations
and setting those prices at the pump
this is a time of war
global peril ukraine
these are not normal times
bring down the price you are charging at
the pump to reflect the cost you are
paying for the product
do it now
do it today
your customers
the american people they need relief now
they need relief now so gas stations
just stop making a profit any profit at
all it's the gas it's the gas station's
fault
biden has blamed everyone else already
he's blamed putin he's blamed oil
company ceos he's blamed everybody but
himself and his own stupid policies and
now he's blaming the poor pakistani
immigrant who runs your local exxon
mobil franchise just lower the prices
just lower the prices why didn't we
think of that it was so easy it was
before us all the time do you know what
the average profit margin is for gas
stations
on average
it's about two cents per gallon
for the government the profit margin on
gas can be extremely high it's about a
dollar eighteen per gallon in california
but for the gas stations
are looking at a profit margin of about
1.4 percent to put that in perspective
that is
way lower than the average profit margin
across all industries which is 7.7
7.7
for everybody across all industries 1.4
for the gas stations it's even lower
significantly lower than the margins on
infamously low margin businesses like
grocery stores grocery stores two and a
half percent car dealerships 3.2
gas stations
1.4
biden wants you to believe that the
reason you're having trouble filling
your tank i just filled my tank this
morning it was absurdly expensive and i
have a very fuel-efficient car
he says the reason that you're having
trouble filling your tank is the couple
of cents per gallon that the stations
are making the meager profit margin that
they have to supplement by selling you
chips and coffee and all that other
slightly higher margin stuff in the gas
station convenience store that's why
the gas stations couldn't drop prices if
they wanted to
biden actually could take some concrete
steps right now to bring prices down
if you really wanted to which he doesn't
i'm michael knowles this is the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment on gosh what was it thursday my
favorite comment thursday was from joni
moroney who says the next troll
assignment for the daily wire is to buy
property next to nancy pelosi and then
convert it into a multi-family unit
complex and fill it with newly arrived
immigrant families that's a great idea
because you see nancy pelosi gavin
newsom all these liberal politicians in
california they think it's a really good
idea to
open up the border flood the state with
with foreign nationals to get rid of
single-family housing you know you're
not allowed to have single-family
housing anymore
where you live where they live it's fine
where you live that's not fine raise the
gas taxes that's that's for you guys
that's all fine just not in my backyard
that's it's the nimby party
not not in my backyard okay well how
about we subject
the
liberal elite democrats especially in
california
to
any of the policies that they push on
everybody else let's subject them to
that for i don't know five minutes see
how quickly those policies go away now
when you want to live like a rich
luxurious elite when you when you at
least want to eat like a rich luxurious
elite you've got to check out good
ranchers happy 5th of july do you know
what i had about a hundred times this
weekend you know what i had i had
delicious good ranchers the steaks and
the burgers and the chicken and it's all
extremely high quality stuff just in
terms of the quality of the beef the
quality of the meat you're getting it's
much higher than what you may have had
for other experiences and at the grocery
store and it comes right to your door
super easy supports american ranches you
know the stuff you're getting is right
from the good old u.s of a more american
than apple pie in the 4th of july really
really wonderful stuff and right now you
can save a ridiculous amount of money if
you use my code knowles you will get 30
off and free shipping on your order
shipping is not cheap okay this is a lot
of top quality meat so make sure you
take advantage of this offer you go to
goodranchers.com
knowles k o w l e s to start bringing
people to the table create some change
in america that begins at the dinner
table ronald reagan told us eat some
seriously delicious food you are going
to thank me so much once you bite into
it you can either order the steaks a la
carte or you can subscribe i recommend
you subscribe head on over right now use
code knowles at goodranchers.com
knowles
if biden wanted to fix the gas issue he
could do it
it wouldn't happen overnight but he
could do it
he would green light the pipeline the
pipelines in america that he shuts down
even as he's green lighting pipelines
for vladimir putin which caused the war
in ukraine according to ukrainian
president zelinski which causes the gas
prices to go up he would green light the
pipelines in america because it's not
just one or two pipelines
when you when you go after and shut down
a pipeline you're signaling to the
industry the government doesn't have
your back so it when you shut down one
oil pipeline in america it means you're
shutting down all the oil pipelines
because there's always going to be local
opposition they're always going to be
some liberal activists who fly out and
try to shut it down the government's
either going to support the pipelines or
not
so he could defend the pipelines he
could issue new oil and gas leases he's
not doing that
promise that he wouldn't do that at all
and what what biden will say is look
this this isn't going to bring the
prices down it would take a year to get
that pipeline up and functioning
okay well biden told us that a year and
a half ago if he had just done it a year
and a half ago
we wouldn't be in this problem right now
wouldn't wouldn't be in this predicament
well it will it'll take a while to get
the oil and natural gas pumping out of
these new leases
okay well sure wish you did it a year
ago
or 18 months ago gosh wouldn't that be
great
then we wouldn't be quite in the same
predicament but he doesn't care enough
to do it he's he's bothered that the gas
prices are hurting democrats chances in
the midterm elections but he is not
bothered enough to compromise his
long-term agenda in the short term yes
they want the lower gas prices because
they think it will help them in the
elections but in the long term the
democrats have been advocating for
higher gas prices when obama was running
an 08 he said yes my plan is going to
result in higher gas prices he
often democrats would bemoan relatively
low gas prices because they said gosh
with these low gas prices people aren't
switching to electric fast enough they
aren't switching to solar fast enough
they aren't taking climate change
seriously enough and climate change is
very very important to the liberal
agenda not because of the environment
not because of the air or the water or
the sun monster or anything like that
it's important
the climate change ideology is important
to the political scheme
of liberalism it's important to the
left's broader political agenda this is
why kamala harris right now she was
asked about high gas prices she started
laughing
what we need to do domestically what we
need to do to bring down the cost of gas
right
right i've seen a meme the other day
that said me googling online how to make
gas at home okay ooh don't do that
please don't do that
you can't afford to fill your car
you can't
you can't you can't afford
don't wait no you can't you can't afford
to drive to the grocery store you
probably can't even afford groceries
there because of how expensive it all is
and you can't afford hold on oh gosh i
need to take a moment here you can't
afford to drive your kids to school
and
your kids probably aren't even allowed
in school still because those damn
teachers unions have kept a jet down
since cohen
oh
what a doozy man so much to laugh about
these days isn't there hi i'm the vice
president of the united states they just
want you to shut up
they're laughing at you they've been
laughing at you for a long time and they
want you to shut up and go away and stop
complaining a biden advisor went on cnn
and and he basically made this point he
he didn't even try to
weasel his way out of the gas issue
the inflation issue the fact that people
are really hurting right now in their in
their budgets
he he didn't do it in the way that
kamala harris does or joe biden does he
just came out and he said look
yeah you're upset about high gas prices
but shut up about it the liberal world
order is at stake
what do you say to those families who
say listen we can't afford to pay 485 a
gallon for months if not years this is
just not sustainable
what you heard from the president today
was a clear articulation of the stakes
this is about the future of the liberal
world order and we have to stand firm
we have to stand firm
now some people are trying to
some liberals are trying to walk back
this comment
because you know that
they call us conspiracy theorists they
co they say we're all wearing tin foil
hats
about international super national
transnational kind of governments
they're going to take away our
sovereignty on the fourth of july of all
days
and then they say things like the
liberal world order or the new world
order or they they use these kinds of
phrases you say wait what was that
phrase you just said they said we didn't
say it
stop repeating what we just said don't
you can't tell us what we just said so
he says that there's a liberal world
order in the liberal world order depends
on
on
the war in ukraine or just voting for
joe biden and not complaining anymore
there is going to be a world order
there is such a thing as a liberal world
order we are living under it
there is going to be a world order there
is going to be some scheme according to
which we organize the various nations
and political bodies of the world and
the major debate that we're having right
now is what is that world order going to
look like
when people talk about a new world order
it doesn't need to be you know the
illuminati and the space aliens
conspiring in a cave somewhere the
question is what is what is the world
order going to look like moving into the
future what the libs one is for us to
have this increasingly secular
increasingly leftist increasingly
homogenized
world
where we all just
look at porn and go to pride parades and
eat mcdonald's
and that that's and they think that
that's going to spread around the world
and that's going to be a great thing and
we're going to lose some of our
political rights as americans and other
people are going to lose some of their
political rights chart their own
national destiny but that's for the best
because that's the liberal world order
the the flag of the liberal world order
is the rainbow flag the values of the
liberal world order is secular leftism
and that's what they want there is an
alternative to that there are a number
of alternatives you could have a
christian world order
that that one seems to have fallen by
the wayside unfortunately in modernity
then then there's a major alternative
right now which is
nationalism in order of nation states
where nations get to chart their own
destiny
the trump election was about this
america first
nationalism that that's what the
question is what is the world order
going to be going into the future do you
want more
rainbow flags over kandahar and pride
parades everywhere and drag queen story
hour and abortion and secular liberalism
or do you want something
more like
a nationalism america first for america
and
not forcing every country in the world
to fall under that secular leftism what
what world order do you want you know
which world order i want i want the one
that isn't going to keep increasing my
gas prices
i i want i like the idea of having the
traditional american way of life and i
also by the way sorry pache cnn and
biden advisor i don't want the high
gas prices
you know when when you've got to fix up
your car
these days it's very very important
you've got to go check out rock auto
right now head on over to rockauto.com
write knowles in their how did you hear
about us box so they know that we sent
you
it is not going to come as any surprise
i'm not the handiest guy in the world
okay i'm not a total aficionado
connoisseur of car parts i know when
something breaks and the mechanic tells
me i need a part well then you got a
choice you can either go to the brick
and mortar auto parts store and it's
going to take a ton of your time and
you're going to get peppered with
questions you don't know the answer to
and then you're going to pay
50 more a hundred percent more sometimes
sometimes even more buddy of mine made a
mistake went to the brick and mortar
store they tried to charge him 400 for a
part where he thought huh wait what was
michael talking about the other day
pulls out his phone goes to rockauto.com
super easy catalog he pulls up the part
really quickly the part's 150 at rock
auto they wanted 400 at the brick and
mortar store don't do that prices are
always reliably low same prices for pros
and do-it-yourselfers super easy catalog
it's all at rockauto.com family business
serving auto parts customers online for
more than 20 years go to rockauto.com
right now see all the parts available
for your car or truck then write knowles
in their how did you hear about us box
so they know that we sent you
the libs when they are constructing a
world order are very focused on global
warming global warming keeps coming back
and it's not because they are concerned
about the weather global warming keeps
coming back because in many ways it is
the linchpin to this liberal world order
here is the
australian ambassador for women and
girls the department of foreign affairs
and trade discussing how global warming
somehow relates to
feminism and domestic violence and let
her tell you herself
as we confront the climate crisis women
and girls human rights must be at the
center of our collective efforts
climate change and its consequences can
exacerbate the risk of sexual and
gender-based violence
this risk is most acute for women and
girls facing multiple and intersecting
forms of discrimination and inequality
including indigenous women and girls
realizing women's and girls human rights
is an important part of securing the
future of our planet and a better future
for us all
how is
recognizing the special rights and
privileges of
indigenous
women and girls of color
what does that have to do with reducing
the global mean temperature
what does that what does that have to do
with
rising sea levels
and sun flares and whatever else
the libs tell us is going to be the
apocalyptic event that that wipes out
the human race what does that i don't i
don't think that is happening
because of the environment because of
the sun or the wind or the oceans or
whatever but what did even if it did
what does that have to do
with
abortion
or
or women's rights or or
intersectionality she actually refers to
intersectionality there among the
indigenous women of color what do the
two have to do with each other
well
quite a lot actually they they're both
part of the leftist ideology
they're both par they're both given as
reasons to give the left whatever they
want well why do you why do we need to
raise taxes on this thing well because
of you know the intersecting
discrimination of the women and the
global warming and the climate and
that's why we need to take away your
rights and your guns and your money and
your your sovereignty and your privilege
because of you know that and the
discrimination and the synergy and and
they just use these liberal buzzwords in
particular climate change because it's
completely unfalsifiable temperature
goes up that's climate change
temperature goes down it's climate
change temperature stays the same you
know what that is that's climate change
in the 70s that we we're headed for a
global ice age what is that well it's
climate change now oh my gosh we're it's
going to be a desert it's going to be
like the sahara all over the earth what
is that well you know what it is that's
climate change climate change is not
it is not so much an end it is not so
much an event to be feared as it is a
political process
that is essential to the liberal world
order kamala harris was just addressing
climate change how are we going to deal
with climate change and she explained
the way we're going to deal with climate
change is we're going to work together
to form a plan to for working together
and then by working together we'll we're
going to
we're going to achieve working together
that is especially true when it comes to
the climate crisis which is why we will
work together and continue to work
together
to address these issues to tackle these
challenges
and to work together as we continue to
work
operating from the new norms rules and
agreements
that we will convene
to work together on to galvanize
global action
with that i thank you all
this is a matter of urgent priority for
all of us
and i know we will work on this together
where is my bong i have a kamala harris
bong i had it in my desk and my
producers took it away from me but i
need the kamala harris bong so that i
can li i don't i'm not a fan of the
haitian oregano as you know but i need
to light it up to understand what she is
talking about most of the time what
she's saying is it's very urgent
global warming climate crisis that's the
new name it's very urgent that's why we
need to work together and figure out a
way to work together
and work work work together together
together there's
inadvertently
a lot of insight in what kamala is
saying here
she's saying that the whole
the whole point
of the global warming fear-mongering
is to get us to work together doesn't
matter what we're working together on
whether we're trying to raise the global
temperature lower the global temperature
cut certain pollution create other
pollution that that is actually beside
the point
the thing that matters is that we work
together and we
lose a little bit more and more of our
national sovereignty and we bind
ourselves together in more international
treaties and institutions and
transnational governing bodies and then
we will have achieved the real goal
which is
working together which is
ever more the liberal world order the
problem is the liberal world order is
not working out very well and people are
seeing this in their pocketbooks they're
seeing this at the tank right now
they're seeing this at the gas prices
and most especially they're seeing this
with their own two eyes
in education in
regular old society and and specifically
with regard to children
we are told that the libs are not
groomers
the pro we've just come to the end of
pride parade we've made it through we
made it through guys a little worse off
than we were when we started but we made
it through
there was a video of a little kid
sweet little kid how old is he probably
four years old or something at a pride
parade looking at some
person
jiggling in an extremely sexual way not
wearing a lot of clothing
these kids staring up
and then some just
just absolute degenerate
dancing and twerking and jiggling around
while this kid looks up i don't know
where this might have been new york
looks sort of like new york i'm not not
quite sure exactly what the street is
no they're not sexualizing the kids no
no they're j they're just offering
educational opportunities it's not
grooming it's not sexual oh that giant
lady or man or i don't know twerking and
jiggling right in the kid's face no
that's nothing there's another video
came out of what looks like a strip club
of a stripper we
blared it out i don't know if it's
a man or a woman or it's a man who
mutilated himself to look like a woman
whoever the person is definitely
has had some work done
walking around holding a little kid by
the hand dancing and stripping
[Music]
and this this dancer has sort of pasties
on so it's
maybe it's
maybe they're skirting some of the laws
here but but it's obviously extremely
indecent it's obviously obscene and and
this dancer is holding the little kid's
hand the most scandalous part of the
video by the way is not that this
dancer prostitute whatever this person
is
it's not even that that person is
holding the kid's hand it's all the
adults who are just sitting there kind
of laughing chuckling
yeah
yeah free expression yeah this is this
is pride let's celebrate let's celebrate
pride
more and more of these videos come out
how many of these videos have i played
on my show
a hundred
i don't know how many of these videos
come out how many of these videos do we
need to see before we realize
that this is a feature not a bug
of pride ideology
of leftist ideology
the
increasing sexualization of little
little little kids i'm not even talking
about
young teenagers
or
fifth grade or sixth grade i'm talking
that girl looks like she's four or five
if that
the increasing sexualization of ever
younger children
is a feature
not a bug
of this leftist ideology they've been
talking about it for 100 years at least
and now they're doing it and we're all
surprised that they're doing it
they're doing it because this is the
leftist vision of liberty on that
tick-tock video they say kids should be
exposed to drag shows this is free
expression man we've got to accustom
them to this when they're very very
young
because the leftist vision of liberty is
that we're all oppressed by society by
the moral order by rules by discipline
by virtue we're all really oppressed by
that and the way to be truly free and
our authentic selves is to throw off all
of those shackles and all of those
limitations so we won't be limited by
the law we won't be limited by the moral
law we won't be limited by biology even
i won't even be limited by my
chromosomes we won't be limited by ages
age of consent statutes we won't be
limited by anything we're just going to
pursue our own
most disgusting appetites
whenever we want and then we're going to
be truly free
we know that's not
liberty the conservatives have a
different view of liberty which is that
the man who sins is a slave to sin and
you shouldn't groom the kids don't groom
the kids grooming the kids is not
liberty if your version of liberty
involves grooming the kids
you've gone down a wrong path you got to
come back you got to change your
your understanding
there's another question that's raised
by this video which is why are these
people not being arrested they should
all be arrested they should all be
thrown in prison and they should
probably throw away the key so why
aren't they
it's not because there aren't laws
against this there are laws against all
this stuff
it's just not prosecuted
there are laws against all this kind of
stuff
and it doesn't get prosecuted it's the
same reason it's the same reason that
blm gets to go kill and rape and kill
and pillage and burn and they basically
get a slap on the wrist and then the
horn hat guy cracks the coors light in
the capital rotunda and they're going to
throw them in solitary and throw away
the key that's why it's not because of
the laws on the books it's because of
the ruling class that is enforcing and
not enforcing
those laws and frankly just enforcing
their own capricious will
it's been a huge few days for the daily
wire and for america last wednesday we
had our biggest live event of the year
backstage live at the ryman where we
celebrated the launch of our expanded
streaming service daily wire plus as
well as the addition of dr jordan
peterson is coming over to the daily
wire then over the weekend we celebrated
the fierce
independence of a country founded on the
principles that we know are worth
fighting for
there has never been a better time to
join with daily wire plus you are
getting everything that you love from
your favorite host
as well as if you're interested ben matt
drew candace plus the entirety of jordan
peterson's existing archive podcasts new
shows and bonus content plus a new
series from prageru out in the fall plus
fearless documentaries and riveting
movies such as what is a woman and
terror on the prairie plus man there's
so much there's so much plus going on
just call me michael knowles plus from
now on that's what you are listener plus
uh plus animated kids shows without a
woke agenda coming soon so join today
start building the future you want to
see by going to dailywireplus.com
we'll be right back with a lot more
you need to pay eight dollars a gallon
for gas to preserve the liberal world
order
uh refund please
um
if if what i am getting in exchange for
my eight dollars a gallon is the liberal
world order
i'm good thanks i'm good
i would like to no thank you
no
even if you discounted 20 off the
liberal world order no thanks there is
no amount of money i want to pay to
preserve because the liberal world order
is not working very well and i think
transgenderism in particular the drag
shows and the grooming and especially
transgenderism is really waking people
up to this fact there was a
a bulletin that came out of the toronto
police department over the weekend i did
not believe this was true
i looked it up it is true
said
toronto police
blue check mark verified account news
release missing woman
ryerson avenue and bat hurst street area
isabella de grace
27 and then
and then you you look at
a a picture of this missing woman and it
the guy looks like joe dirt looks like
it looks like david spade in that movie
he's got the goatee kind of
reddish blonde goatee beard he's got a
man's haircut he's obviously a man i i
then i said this must be
the wrong post uh maybe the the social
media
person for the toronto police just
posted the wrong picture no because then
i looked at the news release
toronto police service requests public's
assistance locating a missing woman she
is described as 5 foot 10
with a thin build shaggy blonde hair and
a full goatee
it's not funny i feel bad for this guy
he's obviously a nut and and he went
missing
full goatee
the toronto police write
she was last seen wearing a black
t-shirt and gray pants police are
concerned about her safety
this is this is the kind of news release
that is sent out by the official
governing body of clown world
this is the the clown world police
department is releasing the head shot of
a dude with a goatee and saying that he
is a woman with a thin build
the transgender issue has become so
prominent one because of what we were
just talking about the libs the
liberation agenda for from the libs
is
is constantly
accelerating so it's not just being
liberated from certain laws or being
liberated from certain traditional
social mores or being liberated from
certain institutions including the
family or being liberated from certain
symbols it's being liberated from
biology from human nature from
everything so that's why the libs are
pushing it in part the trans agenda is
really prominent for the conservatives
because it's waking us up to the fact
that we can no longer trust our
authorities
the liberal world order we can't trust
it
if the toronto police really believe
that shaggy goatee guy is a woman
then i can't trust the toronto police i
can't trust the toronto police or any
any
one of these similar institutions i
can't trust them on issues of sex
i can't trust them on anything
if you don't know that that dude is not
a chick
you
you don't know anything and so now i've
got to look out for myself now i see no
reason to support the continued power
and rule of these people who don't know
the most basic things about human nature
speaking of the police there was this
horrible shooting that took place
yesterday there were a couple of
shootings actually the one that first
started to trend was a shooting in
highland park illinois
where at least six people were killed 24
wounded the numbers may be higher now
they were killed by this young man
who had really creepy stuff on the
internet and the usual suspects are all
bickering over whether he was a democrat
or a republican
and the the libs are saying he was a
republican because there's a picture of
him with a trump flag
and then the conservatives are saying
well he was only ironically wearing the
trump flag and actually if you look at
his social media history he was posting
all sorts of extremely left-wing things
uh apparently on his twitter account he
was liking all of these tweets about how
they need to arrest all the january 6
people so i don't
i don't have an opinion really one way
or the other i haven't looked into it
that much i don't really care
if you look at the guy he's got crazy
colored hair and all sorts of face
tattoos and
he doesn't exactly look like a trump
supporter okay he definitely looks much
more like a radical leftist but i don't
i don't know i don't know maybe he's a
maybe he's just a psycho he has some
music videos on the internet
that don't seem they don't seem
left-wing exactly they don't seem
right-wing exactly they seem demonic
uh so whatever his politics are i i
don't
i'm not really all that interested in it
the reason this is becoming a major
headline unlike other
mass killings including at parades like
the waukesha christmas parade the reason
this one's becoming a mass killing is
because it it at least checks some of
the boxes of the left-wing narrative so
it the it's a young white man that
usually will encourage the media to
report on a killing
uh
he
he might have some tie to even plausibly
being viewed as a right winger so that
checks another box for the media
there are lots of other
mass killings that are not reported and
that's because they don't they don't
check those boxes again that's the way
the media are going to behave it's just
a horrific event
uh in any case really really awful stuff
on the 4th of july
marge taylor green who is a conservative
congressman she tweeted out when are we
going to have an honest conversation
about drug abuse mental illness and
ssris those are a certain type of
depression drug and deadly side effects
are we really going to keep pretending
or covering for big pharma because i'm
absolutely done with the political plays
on this bs so people people raise
different questions about what is
causing this the libs say that the cause
of mass shootings and mass killings is
guns
of course guns have existed for a very
very long time and all throughout
american history
and if the liberal argument is that
these mass shootings are a newer
phenomenon which is a dubious argument
to begin with but let's let's just go
with it then the thing that changed
obviously is not the guns the guns have
remained basically the same but they say
it's the guns then conservatives will
say well it's maybe fatherlessness well
it's maybe or sometimes they'll blame
video games sometimes they'll say well
there are obviously cultural aspects
here maybe it's this isolation maybe as
marge retailer agreement is suggesting
maybe it's these depression drugs that a
lot of people are on
again on this issue i'm not expressing
an opinion one way or the other i think
a lot of these squabbles over well it
was caused by this no it's caused by
this no it's your team no it's your team
a lot of that is you often beside the
point
but but the broader point that green is
making here on the depression drugs is a
really really important one
america is totally hooked we are drug
addicts on these depression pills did
you know that more than one in eight
americans regularly takes depression
drugs
did you know that even kids regularly
take these kinds of depression drugs
but before kovid the number of kids aged
12 to 19 who take these depression drugs
regularly
is one in 29
and since kova those numbers certainly
have gone up
one in 29 kids are taking depression
drugs isn't that a problem
put aside the shooting for a second put
aside the killers the killers who have
often been on these depression drugs
just take that just focus on the drugs
don't you think that's a problem when a
huge portion of your country including
kids are hooked on their drug addicts
for these very particular psycho
psychological drugs i think that's a
problem
and watch watch right now the liberals
rally around ssris and other depression
drugs with greater ferocity than they
rallied around the covid shots those
very you know this very safe and
effective covet shots because we totally
should trust the medical establishment
they never get anything wrong they they
totally know the difference between a
man and a woman they're so smart they
know everything watch them rally around
these drugs
it's really really weird because nothing
says fight the power quite like
consistently shilling for big farmer
right
the depression drug seemed to me a big
problem i'm not saying there's no use
for these depression drugs i'm not
saying no one should take these
depression drugs
but
if a huge portion of your country is
regularly
dulling
some kind of pain that they
feel with drugs
and increasing those numbers clearly
there is a problem
someone someone said to me when i made
this point on social media they said
well michael where's your md you're not
a medical doctor how dare you spat off
on this that's true you know who a
medical doctor is uh dr richard levine
the man who thinks that he's a woman
he's actually not just a medical doctor
he's the assistant secretary of health
so yeah that's true i don't he and i
have different degrees i don't have the
same degree
in medicine and scientific reality that
the man who insists that he's a woman
and advocates putting kids on cross-sex
hormones and sterilizing them and giving
them osteoporosis and mutilating their
bodies forever we don't have the same
degree so you're right i guess you
should listen to his opinion because
he's he obviously knows what he's
talking about he has an md after all and
stiletto heals an address and i i don't
have that md so i guess what i don't
know you you listeners out there you
don't have an md
so how dare you question
the medical estate how dare you question
dr fauci
dr levine and all those geniuses who no
i
i am not saying this to flatter you or
pander or anything like that
i trust
the medical opinion of every single
person regardless of your political
views of every single person listening
to this podcast right now i trust your
medical opinion
much more than i trust the opinion
of richard levine or dr fauci or or any
of the rest of them
because
you at least have a a basic modicum of
common sense you probably have a great
deal more than that
but you've got something
that the medical establishment does not
it's it's just like the toronto police
issue
the problem with
the medical establishment embracing all
this kind of quackery and then trying to
trying to solve the problems created by
their quackery by just plying us all
with drugs all the time is that they
don't have any credibility at all
there was a liberal blue check who last
night when i made this point on the
depression pills he said well michael
you ever consider that maybe america is
just a depressing place
i thought well i don't think it's a
depressing place
still i'm still pro-america i still
still look at fireworks on the 4th of
july
take that grill pill you know wave my
american flag so i don't think it's a
depressing place but even if it were
doesn't that only bolster my point he
ended up deleting the tweet so i think
he probably agreed that it it did
bolster my point
if the thing that is causing you
your these problems is environmental and
social maybe drugs aren't the answer
these drugs are supposed to address very
specific chemical and psychological
problems
if your problems are not coming from
within you they're coming from without
it's because the people you live with or
it's because you don't like being in a
society with guns or it's because you
don't like the founding fathers or the
constitution or whatever
you don't solve that problem with drugs
you solve that problem with
politics you solve that problem with
society you solve that problem with
getting to know your community and
adjust and acclimating yourself to your
community into reality which is
something the libs don't want you to do
so they apply you with drugs
one way
i admit america is a little bit more
depressing today than it was
even in recent years
things are getting you know the economy
is no good and we're grooming the kids
and that's no good and we got rid of roe
v wade that's actually great that's a
huge massive white pill great bit of
hope that we've been getting but yeah
it's a it's a bit of a mixed bag sure
one of the reasons is and this comes
from the late conservative philosopher
roger scrutin
if you want people to love
your country
you've got to give them
a country that is lovable
you got to give them a place that is
beautiful you got to give them a place
that inspires and evokes their love and
this this gets to an issue we talked
about last week another thing i got in
trouble for on social media
i i posted two pictures of of picasso
paintings one from when he was a
teenager and one from later in his
career and the early one is beautiful
and the later one was of the weeping
woman and from his much more abstract
period and it's an ugly painting i'm not
saying it's not technically proficient
picasso was a master artist
and i asked the question i said why
would someone who can paint a beautiful
thing choose to paint an ugly thing
and this
evoked a lot of ire from people
and it even inspired someone there's a
guy at the the independent the british
newspaper
to write an entire column
about
how i prefer picasso's earlier work to
his later work an angry column about
why i prefer beautiful art to ugly art
and the headline was what got me
the headline is why are right wingers so
afraid of modern art
i am not afraid of modern art let me
turn the question back on the lips why
do the lips always equate
disapproval with fear
if you disapprove of men putting on
dresses and pretending to be women it's
a phobia that's a transphobia you're
phobic even fox news did this when fox
news ran that segment promoting trancing
the kids the reporter at the end he said
he said you know people fear what they
don't understand and that's why we need
to trans the kids sometimes we fear what
we don't understand you might fear
ghosts
you don't understand sometimes we fear
what we do understand
like bears
i understand bears and i fear them if i
ran into a bear in the woods i would i
would be afraid
and sometimes
we disapprove of things we don't quite
understand like demons i don't i don't
don't understand demons don't approve of
them i'm anti-demon
and sometimes we disapprove of things
that we do understand
like modern art or transgenderism or
grooming the kids or all the stuff that
the libs want to do
you can disapprove of something
without
fearing it but the libs the libs have to
pretend that it's a fear usually an
irrational fear of phobia because they
want to pretend that conservatism
doesn't make any sense that it's just a
series of irritable mental gestures to
quote the liberal lionel trilling many
many moons ago but it's not we just look
at it you you look at modern art put
picasso aside because he is a very good
artist even though a lot of his work is
very ugly but you know you think of
marcel duchamp the uh the guy who
pretended that a urinal was was a great
work of art you look at that you say you
know it's not that i don't get it i get
it i understand it
i'm not it's not that i fear it i'm not
afraid of the urinal it's just ugly
and i don't like it and i think it
should be discouraged it's not that i
don't get men putting on stilettos and
jiggling at the library i get i
understand it it's not even that i'm
afraid of the men
i just disapprove of it and i think it
should be
discouraged
why is that so complicated for the libs
speaking of fear-mongering
california governor gavin newsom gavin
newsom right now is running
on
freedom
it's independence day so let's talk
about what's going on in america freedom
it's under attack in your state
republican leaders they're banning books
making it harder to vote restricting
speech in classrooms even criminalizing
women and doctors i urge all of you
living in florida to join the fight or
join us in california but we still
believe in freedom freedom of speech
freedom to choose freedom from hate and
the freedom to love
don't let them take your freedom paid
for by news and for california governor
2022
i
moved out of california
because
not only was i not allowed perfect
freedom in the abstract i wasn't allowed
to go into grocery stores without
covering my face like it was a like it
was a burqa
like i was living in saudi arabia and i
had
i had to wear the full niqab
i fled california
because
i i had to give away
so much of my money to the government i
had to work half the year for gavin
newsom
and then the california franchise tax
board continues to come after you
wherever you go like like one of the
five it's the sixth family you got the
five families in new york you got the
sixth family it's the franchise tax
board in california
i i fled california because the
regulations are so onerous that you
don't even know when you're violating
them
regulations on your cars regulations on
your water regulations on your schools
regulations on your church they were
closing our churches
you weren't allowed to do anything in
california and now he's running on
freedom
and he says ron desantis he opposes
freedom because he doesn't want gay porn
in kindergarten
he's banning books california bans books
you're not allowed to teach the bible in
schools
you're not allowed to teach the bible in
schools that's fine that's good that's
freedom you're not allowed to teach gay
porn in kindergarten that's
well that's terrible that is a horrible
oppressive that's a tyranny it's like a
dictatorship
and they believe it
they believe that during during covet it
was even at the end of cove it was over
at this point
my pregnant wife we were in la lax
and because i travel a lot for work i
joined the lounge where you get to go
and get a cup of coffee and a little
food before before you fly and so we go
into the lounge and my very pregnant
wife just needed to use the restroom and
get a glass of water they wouldn't let
her in they wouldn't let her in because
she had she had some kind of food with
her and she's pregnant she's trying to
eat you know things like that and they
said no sorry
you can't you have to stay out it's
order of the state order of the county
it's the least free state in america
but but for the libs freedom means doing
drugs for the libs freedom means
stopping whoever you want to stop
for the libs freedom means taking kids
to strip clubs for the that's what and
they they mean that
for the libs freedom means mutilating
your body so you look like the opposite
sex
and that
that is that is a kind of
misunderstanding of freedom i see how
you could arrive at that conclusion
but that's not that's not what the
founding fathers thought it's not what
the fourth of july is about that's not
what fruit tree true freedom is
true freedom
is higher than that
true freedom is being in command of
yourself and your appetites and your
base desires and having
discipline and having a rational will
and pursuing that that higher political
freedom charting your own course for
your community and for your nation
being a real citizen accepting reality
and flourishing within the bounds of
reality
everyone believes that he is fighting
for freedom
everyone believes it
the terrorists in the middle east they
think they're fighting for freedom
the
western powers that go in and fight the
terrorists we say we're fighting for
freedom the libs
in california who are fighting to raise
your taxes and trans your kids they
think they're fighting for freedom the
conservatives in tennessee and texas
who are doing the opposite of that they
we believe that we are fighting for
freedom too we're all we all are
motivated to fight for freedom the
question is what is freedom
are there limits to freedom yeah of
course there have to be there limits to
everything what are those limits
is freedom
the freedom to mutilate your body and go
into the girl's locker room or is
freedom the freedom of young girls to
change without a man pulling out his
genitals in front of them
what is what is that freedom
we're arguing about freedom in the
abstract is not going to get anybody
anywhere you've got to get specific
you've got to talk about real ways of
life you've got to talk about specific
political rights and how they're applied
in society that's that's the only way
you're going to do it even
even the libs
are waking up to the fact that the
left-wing version of liberty and freedom
is not real freedom
when you get specific
even the libs wake up to it bette midler
my absolute favorite twitter account
bette midler tweets out quote
women of the world we're being stripped
of our rights over our bodies
our lives and even our name
they don't call us women anymore they
call us birthing people or menstruators
or even people with vaginas don't let
them erase you every human on earth owes
you
good
keep going bet
you're you're on a roll you're getting
somewhere now
who is it bet
that is that is taking away the name of
women who is it that is erasing women
from
sports and from the locker rooms and
from reality and who's doing that and
calling
birthing people and menstruators and who
is it us
or is it no
ah it's so wonderful to watch
someone realize
that the thing they have been fighting
for
is really bad
to realize that the people they've been
fighting were right all along and she
was starting to do that i'm not sure
she's going to go all the way
she's starting
to realize that
wow maybe huh
maybe this transgenderism is not the
right thing after all this is
this is what the liberal world order is
giving you
okay and you're you're even seeing it
now in around the world you are seeing
protests around the world protesting
roe v wade the roe v wade overruling
you're seeing protests in france we
don't have time to get to it today we'll
have to get to it tomorrow you're seeing
protests in france where the abortion
laws are stricter than they are in the
united states are much stricter than
they are in the united states you are
seeing because there is this thing that
that biden advisor was totally right
there is this thing called the liberal
world order and the the reality of the
liberal world order is pride flags
everywhere and transiting the little
kids and promoting
all sorts of
awful gross terrible things and raising
your gas prices okay do you want that is
that is that worth eight bucks a gallon
it isn't to me maybe it's time to chart
an alternative course happy fourth of
july what a great happy fifth of july
what a great way to do it yesterday we
commemorated today we start fighting
again i'm michael knowles this the
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico
associate producer justine turley audio
mixer mike coromina and hair and makeup
by cherokee heart michael knowles show
is a daily wire production copyright
daily wire 20 22.
john vickley here daily wire
editor-in-chief wake up every morning
with our show morning wire where we
bring you all the news that you need to
know in 15 minutes or less
join me and my co-host georgia hal for
daily coverage of all the biggest
stories on morning wire